comme annoncé dans les titres maintenant
le château de versailles et de château
de versailles est visité par plus de 3
millions de personnes chaque année et en
restauration plus ou moins constant tout
de même en ce moment les travaux ont
pris de l'ampleur
réfection des jardins des fontaines
notamment et de la célèbre galerie des
glaces imaginé par mansare 73 mètres de
long en travaux jusqu'en 2007 pour
autant l'endroit restera accessible aux
visiteurs ce chantier a été entièrement
financé son savoir par un mécène privé
en l'occurrence groupe vinci isabelle
bechler à new york
le commando anti poussière de la galerie
des glaces est exclusivement féminin en
ce premier jour de travaux sur la voûte
les aspirateurs des restauratrices sa
tata 50 ans de particules accumulés dans
les sculptures depuis la dernière
campagne de travaux des années 1950
ça va répondre
35e beaucoup d'eau
leur meilleur de lui même
prenant place mais aussi la poussière et
pas beaucoup d'importance
trois cent vingt ans après la
réalisation de ce plafond par charles le
brun
même les pinceaux de ces dames doivent
prendre des précautions note vous les
soulèvements c'est parti vous voyez vous
ces partis qui risque de soulever et
pendant le dépoussiérage pour éviter d'y
toucher pour éviter de faire partir des
écailles
c'est un ouvrage complexe que cette
voûte où se combinent sculpture dorures
stuc toi les fresques
le tout dans le plus beau trompe-l'oeil
france ait connu un trompe l'oeil à
l'italienne avant tout faux dévots serré
parce que je sais pas si vous pouvez
voir à l'image la quantité d'aidé des
poussières qu'elle est déposée sous la
surface et celui-ci cinq surfaces
verticales
mais sous la corniche il ya des amas
très important voici comment le brun a
relaté les vingt premières années du
règne de louis xiv
voici ce que viennent voir 3 millions de
visiteurs chaque année
il était urgent qu'il ne soit pas trop
frustré par l'échafaudage et la
restauration
on a donc gardé visible un tiers de la
galerie des glaces tout en tentant de
recréer la perspective et la magie du
lieu
le tout étant que les visiteurs ne soit
pas gênée d'avoir des restaurateurs au
dessus de leur tête
mon père est un petit peu déçue sort
était magnifique de voir la galerie des
glaces en entier mais ce qu'on envoie
est déjà assez fabuleux est à couper le
souffle le château et à droite on a
vraiment rien de tel aux états unis tard
trois cadenas state en trois années de
restauration de ce lieu historique c'est
quand même là que le traité de
versailles a mis un point d'orgue à la
première guerre mondiale 9 millions de
visiteurs vont emprunter ce tunnel de
miroirs qui permet la restauration de la
voûte presque à leur insu